je voudrais d'abord je dois d'abord
remercier nicolas sarkozy d'avoir voulu
organiser ce conseiller national comme
ils s'organisent depuis depuis hier
c'est formidable de pouvoir débattre de
pouvoir parler de pouvoir échanger c'est
formidable de se rencontrer de façon
aussi sérieuse et de façon aussi solide
merci nicolas pour ce conseil national
qui le premier dans ce dans ce style et
je pense que chacune et chacun apprécie
cela et je pense qu'on peut être
d'accord avec ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ça je voudrais aussi vous dire que
ce conseil national
il était pas si évident que cela quand
on se reporte une année en arrière le
parti était vraiment en difficulté dans
une situation calamiteuse
il relevait de complications absolument
épouvantable aujourd'hui il est il gagne
les élections aujourd'hui ils
l'organisent des primaires il faut
beaucoup de maturité pour organiser des
primaires est aujourd'hui notre parti
politique est en ordre de marche pour
ces élections si fondamental pour notre
pays que 2010 est merci aussi nicolas
pour avoir tué avec tant de talent
rétablir reconstruire remodeler ce parti
politique et en faire les républicains
auxquels nous sommes fiers d'appartenir
je voudrais vous parler de notre famille
politique je voudrais vous parler du
débat pourrait vous parler de nos
convictions et bien sûr de la france
notre famille politique c'est une
histoire ce sont des hommes ce sont des
femmes ce sont des militants ce sont des
élus se sont aussi des électeurs
notre famille politique c'est celle de
la droite et si celle du centre je suis
de droite
je suis d'une droite gaulliste je suis
d'une droite humaniste je suis d'une
droite qui aiment la liberté qui m
l'autorité qui demande l'autorité je
crois en la france et en europe
et j'estime que notre pays a encore et
toujours un message à délivrer au monde
je suis de droite et je pense que la
souveraineté ne se partage pas ni notre
souveraineté militaire ni bien sûr notre
souveraineté économique et lorsque nous
décidons de la partager ça peut arriver
et je pense à notre souveraineté
monétaire à l'euro alors la france ne
doit pas jamais se mettre en position de
subir ma famille politique c'est vous
dans les bons jours comme dans les
mauvais jours
une famille politique c'est évidemment
aussi un lien un lieu un lieu de
compétition on a beaucoup parlé de la
primaire et je voudrais dire que cette
primaire elle n'est pas au dessus de la
famille politique elle n'est que
l'expression de cette famille politique
cher thierry solère et c'est ce que nous
essayons de bâtir tous ensemble alors
une famille politique c'est évidemment
aussi une famille qui débat une famille
c'est pas le silence il ya des silences
dans les faits me parfois vous le savez
et quand cistac en silence s'installe
mais y'a plus de familles politiques
alors on doit faire vivre le débat on
doit nourrir le débat
on doit progresser par le débat on doit
accepter le débat on se doit aussi
accepter que lorsque le débat s'achève
parce qu'un jour il s'achève
eh bien il ya une majorité et une
minorité est dans une famille politique
peuvent vivre ensemble une majorité et
une minorité d'idées qui varie selon les
sujets selon les enjeux selon les
priorités le débat il est là le débat il
est maintenant le débat il est sans
tabou le débat il est vivifiant de débat
il est républicain débattront se
respecter cc mais c'est allé plus loin
c'est se comprendre il n'y a pas de
république aujourd'hui sans débat à mes
chers amis nos convictions
une famille politique c'est un débat
c'est évidemment aussi un socle de
convictions
je voudrais en évoquer quelques unes ma
conviction d'abord c'est que la france
elle a besoin de l'europe et que
l'europe évidemment a besoin de la
france et qu'une france faible affaibli
l'europe c'est une situation dangereuse
et nous y sommes la france aujourd'hui
est faible et aujourd'hui l'europe
connaît des difficultés sans pareil je
crois que le maillon fort de notre
société
c'est l'entreprise ya des chefs
d'entreprise ici certains chefs
d'entreprise ont posé des questions hier
et aujourd'hui l'entreprise elle crée la
richesse l'entreprise
elle crée l'emploi elle est le lieu
naturel du progrès technologique
elle est le lieu naturel de l'innovation
elle est le lieu du dialogue social elle
est le lieu du sens donné au travail je
crois à l'équité pas à l'égalitarisme
qui égalise tout n'importe quand
n'importe comment
je crois à l'équité entre les français
et je crois à l'équité entre les
territoires
quelques exemples je pense quelle
situation égale on doit avoir une
retraite égal quand on est fonctionnaire
ou quand on travaille dans le secteur
privé
on doit avoir la même retraite si on a
travaillé autant de temps avec les mêmes
qualifications
il faut sortir de ces inéquité que les
français ne supportent plus je pense qu
à revenu égal on doit payer la même
fiscalité
les revenus issus de l'aide sociale
doivent subir les mêmes fiscalité au
delà des allocations familiales qui sont
une compensation à revenu égal c'est la
même fiscalité fiscalité égal je crois
qu'à travail égal
on doit être traité de la même manière
parlons-en taxi parlons en vtc
parlons-en aux hôteliers parlons-en à
celles et ceux qui utilisent airbnb
cette société qui est en train de
changer
elle doit reposer sur des valeurs et
dans cette valeur il y est évidemment
pour traiter de la même manière
celles et ceux qui font les mêmes
métiers ou qui rendent les mêmes
services quelle que soit la manière dont
ils rendent service
je crois aussi que les territoires
ruraux valent bien les territoires
urbains ou périurbains
nous n'avons pas fait suffisamment pour
la ruralité en france depuis longtemps
et ça devrait être une priorité
et puis je pense que s'il ya un régime
spécial c'est parce que la situation est
spécial et si ce n'est pas le cas alors
il n'y a pas de régime spécial
il faut mettre fin aux régimes spéciaux
quand ils ne veulent rien dire
je crois enfin qu aucune solidarité ne
peut se faire à la charge du générations
futures
qu'y at il
plus injuste qu y at il de plus brutale
qu'y at il de plus violent que de faire
payer par nos propres enfants
les dépenses sociales de nos générations
c'est inacceptable on ne peut pas
accepter que la santé que la retraite
que la solidarité nationale soit payée
par celles et ceux qui aujourd'hui ne
sont pas en âge d'activité puis je crois
à la famille comme socle de notre
société
enfin je crois que il faut combattre
cette terrible société de la
malveillance que nous subissons celle
qui insulte tout seul qui s'est dit ou
celle qui jalousent tout cette société
n'est pas la france et puis je crois en
la france de nos enfants je crois au
travail on mérite à la responsabilité
nous l'avons dit souvent hier et
aujourd'hui je crois à une france à la
fois mondiale et qui sait se protéger de
la mondialisation alors ses convictions
et sans doute beaucoup d'autres
voulaient partager aux nous les nous les
partageons ensemble elles nous
réussissent elles nous réunissent nos
convictions
ce que ce à quoi nous croyons nous le
diront dans un projet est un projet
s'est pas uniquement un programme
c'est évidemment aussi une vision c'est
pas le concours lépine de l'idée la plus
originale pour redresser la france
on a besoin de faire avec courage ce
qu'ont fait d'autres pays
réformer notre marché du travail
pourquoi créer un véritable marché du
travail et pas le marché du chômage
qu'on subit aujourd'hui c'est baisser
puissamment les impôts et les charges
pour libérer les entreprises et pour
favoriser l'investissement et puis c b6
encore plus massivement les dépenses
publiques et toof l'économie et qui ne
protège aujourd'hui plus personne et
certainement pas les plus faibles
d'entre nous enfin on a besoin de clarté
beaucoup plus que de calculs petits ou
grands et dans le débat qui nous a que
nous avons eues sur la déchéance de
nationalité
moi je pense que quand il ya un débat
compliqué un peu comme le général de
gaulle qui pensaient qu en s'envolant
vers l'orient compliqué il fallait à un
moment donné essayez d'avoir quelques
idées simples et bien dans cette
déchéance de nationalité il ya quand
même une idée simple est-ce qu'on
ve ou est ce qu'on ne veut pas la
déchéance de nationalité pour celles et
ceux qui portent les armes contre notre
propre veillée contre nos propres
valeurs
si on considère que nous ne voulons pas
de cela
si on considère que c'est inacceptable
si nous considérons que la déchéance de
nationalité est une réponse fort
symbolique mais forte vis-à-vis de cela
alors on vote pour la déchéance de
nationalité
quel que soit le vecteur juridique qui
nous est proposé enfin la france elle
est enfin c'est lorsque la france est
grande que les français sont heureux
aujourd'hui la france est faible parfois
humilié sans ressort elle est toujours
plein de mauvais remords c'est pas comme
ça qu'on construit l'avenir les
socialistes et françois hollande à leur
tête des grades avec méthode
ce qui fait la france l'audace le
courage la fierté ya de lourds nuages
qui plaide qui planent aujourd'hui au
dessus de nos têtes le bras exit les
sortie éventuelle de l'europe de
l'angleterre et de la grande bretagne
ce serait évidemment absolument
catastrophiques pour l'europe
l'endettement excessif des nations la
crise financière qui frappe les marchés
la déflation l'effondrement du prix des
matières premières la crise des migrants
il y à des risques de plus en plus
inquiétant est en face de ces risques
françois hollande nous bâti un
remaniement qui évidemment ne veut rien
dire
bien risques j'ai pas évoqué c'est au
fond quand même encore 16 mois de
françois hollande c'est un risque assez
assez perceptible aujourd'hui partout
les par tous les français
et ce remaniement c'est une sacrée
mascarade
laurent l'a bien dit tout à l'heure
quand on veut être madame cos à monsieur
macron comment peut-on dire qu'il y ait
la moindre qu il n'y a aucune cohérence
ya aucune corps et son record le
problème en réalité c'est pas le
gouvernement
le problème c'est le président le vrai
remaniement c'est celui de 2017 c'est
quand françois hollande partira sinon il
n'y a pas d'avenir et on peut pas
inscrire la france dans un avenir
durable et
cohérent et les résultats sont là car la
réalité c'est qu'au bout de quatre ans
on est jugé aux résultats les résultats
sont là mauvais triste sinistre face à
cela
face au décrochage du pays je veux dire
que notre responsabilité
les républicains elle est énorme on doit
proposer des mesures claires et fortes
on doit le dire on doit dire ce que nous
ferons et puis on doit le faire
évidemment après on doit gouverner
autrement en étant plus attentifs aux
messages de nos concitoyens on ne doit
pas transformer la primaire en un combat
de rue
les français ne nous le pardonnerait pas
et il aurait bien raison
nous devons enfin pour terminer être à
la hauteur de cette france qui vient et
ne pas s'accrocher à celles qui s'en va
la nostalgie n'est pas le meilleur des
sentiments pour inventer l'avenir les
racines sont une identité
l'histoire est un repère la france est
multiple et unique à la fois notre
responsabilité politique c'est de
magnifier nos rêves et de révéler nos
talents de rendre possible l'avenir
cette france qui vient elle doit pas
nous faire peur
bien au contraire ni replier ni
recroquevillé mais ouverte et
bienveillante solide sur ses valeurs et
réconciliée avec elle même si nous le
voulons la france qui vient sera
meilleure que celle d'aujourd'hui
c'est notre responsabilité c'est notre
devoir c'est le sens de l'alternance que
nous proposerons dire la vérité aux
français sur la france agir vite agir
fort agir ensemble
c'est le message que nous entendons si
notre ligne de conduite si notre ligne
politique
c'est la ligne nicolas des républicains